تقييم البينتاجون لمسار الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد ووصف رئيس الاركان مارك ميلي له
بانه سيكون صعبا وطويلا تقاطع مع تقديرات
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين بان الهجوم يواجه
تعثرا وتحذيراتهم من مغبه تباطؤه اذا لم
تحصل كييف على مزيد من السلاح في هذا
السياق يتهم الرئيس الاوكراني فلودومير
زيلينسكي بعض من وصفهم بالشركاء الغربيين
دون ان يحددهم بالمماطله في بدء تدريب
الطيارين على قياده طائرات اف 16 تمهيدا
للحصول لاحقا على المقاتلات الامريكيه
التي قد تحدث فرقا في معادله المعارك
الجاريه اتهام الرئيس الاوكراني جاء خلال
لقائه في كييف رئيس الوزراء الاسباني
مشيرا الى عدم وجود جدول زمني واضح لمهمات
التدريب
من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء الاسباني ان دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي قدمت حتى الان مساعدات
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 12 مليار دولار
وفي وقت سابق قررت دول في النيتو البدء في
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين وزيره الدفاع
الهولنديه قالت ان البرنامج التدريبي الذي
تدعمه واشنطن سيشمل بلجيكا ولوكسمبورج كما
عرضت فرنسا وبريطانيا المساعده يضاف الى
هذه الدول الدنمارك التي تحدثت مصادر
اعلاميه عن بدء تدريبها الطيارين
الاوكرانيين في هذه الاثناء تنقل واشنطن
بوست عن مسؤول امريكي ان مدير وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
سرا واجتمع وكبار مسؤولي الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه واستنادا الى الصحيفه فان
المسؤولين الاوكرانيين كشفوا للمسؤول
الامريكي عن استراتيجيتهم لاستعاده ما
تسيطر عليه القوات الروسيه من اراض والبدء
بالتفاوض مع موسكو بنهايه العام